l'intérieur de pierre qui ont quasiment
achevé c'est ça la pose des balustrade
une nouvelle jeunesse pour le château de
Dampierre les nouvelles façades du
monument ont été révélées au public en
juillet dernier remplacement des briques
de la toiture nouvel enduite et bois de
charpente renouvelée là la seule coup et
bien les couleurs de Dampierre
reviennent l'ocre la brique tout ça
resplendit et tout ça c'était refait
admirablement par tous les compagnons le
propriétaire Monsieur Mullier même n'en
revient pas
je vais répéter ces mots qui dit en fait
mon château est joli il y avait pas
imaginé que ce château était si joli
parce que quand il avait acheté
évidemment il était dégradé près de 300
personnes on devrait depuis 2020 à
l'embellissement du château un des plus
gros chantiers privés sur un monument
historique ouvert au public en France
les ouvriers peaufinent actuellement les
derniers détails sur la base des murs on
remet des petits caillots
depuis le début août et bien on a engagé
des travaux sur les pavillons d'entrée
les pavillons d'entrée ce sont les
pavillons qui sont au bord de la route à
l'heure actuelle ils sont bâchés par ces
énormes bâches qui couvrent ces
pavillons on va refaire les couvertures
les charpentes les menuiseries les tout
ce qui est maçonnerie les rénovations
intérieures du château débuteront
courant en 2023 après la mise aux normes
du réseau destinisme do et d'électricité
sur ce site classé monument historique
une étude doit être menée au préalable
par des archéologues avant les
raccordements la Direction Régionale des
Affaires Culturelles demande et oblige à
ce qu'il y ait des fouilles
archéologiques puisque ces travaux par
définition vont être destructeurs et
donc les archéologues viennent en amont
des travaux ou alors accompagnent les
travaux pour enregistrer l'information
archéologique contenue dans sous-sol si
l'intérieur du château ne sera
accessible que début 2025 le jardin de
90 hectares reste cependant ouvert au
public pour en profiter il faudra avant
la fermeture annuelle le 6 novembre
prochain